because we're in Hollywood a lot of
stars have step forward to speak up for
you to hold fundraisers to raise money
is there anyone who still gets you star
struck oh my gosh with George Clooney
and Amal did that event for me at their
home I was starstruck I mean obviously
I'm a huge fan of George's and I hadn't
yet met Amal but I knew people who knew
her because she is a human rights lawyer
which I am enthusiastically impressed by
so the idea that they were gonna do this
and then we got to spend some personal
time together that that was pretty
starstruck each time was amazing huh it
was it was great it was just terrific
did mrs. Clinton just get all twinkly I
dare well it's okay because George had
that same totally smitten look at her
back in 2003 actually lots of stars have
sort of a crush on Hillary but no one
more than Katy Perry Katy Perry wore
that t-shirt now that you can buy that
Hillary Clinton is a badass how was your
mom a badass well how much time do we
have Kevin I'm just in awe of her
strength and her grace and I hope that
my daughter Charlotte and her future
little sister little brother feel the
same way about me someday that I feel
about my mom that's right Chelsea's
about to be a mom again I just get more
and more pregnant not just inevitable 19
month old Charlie it's gonna be a big
sister will you even put a nursery in
the White House oh my gosh of course
easy question um I am thrilled that
Charlotte recognizes me calls me grandma
they'll FaceTime me every day she asked
about her grandma every day so you
FaceTime oh my god yes it was a date for
grandparents Kevin I'm convinced of that
Chelsea and Mark would video Charlotte
and when she was really little they
would they would make a sign which would
say good luck grandma right wait and
then it was her animal noises so she
could roar like a lion I would say you
know if Charlotte like roar like a lion
for your grandma she'd go wrong that's
right it's interesting we've watched
this mother/daughter duo really change
over the years Hillary has definitely
evolved her look in Chelsea well she's
gone from tight
girls straight and chic but here's the
big question how do they handle the
haters for better or worse I don't
remember a time that she wasn't being
attacked by people I'm more concerned
about how alex went into my daughter hmm
how will you she isn't so aware but
she's becoming more aware and so I'm
more focused on that because I know my
mom can take care of herself but did you
know Hillary's toughest critic was
actually her mom
sadly Dorothy passed away in 2011 about
a year and a half after Chelsea said I
do this is at your wedding but it's with
your mom and you know do you your mom
raised you to do great things and to do
your best right right foot right now how
proud would she'd be she would be
excited she'd be very proud but she'd
also still be giving me advice which oh
oh oh yeah oh my goodness like I'm not
sure you should have said that or did
you really need to wear that what's a
mother always a mother